sie sind wirklich super mysteriös die
tiefen und absolut geraden risse in der
eiskruste des saturnmondes enceladus
doch woher kommen diese
aufsehenerregenden furchen die oft auch
als tigerstreifen bezeichnet werden ein
us forschungsteam ist diesem rätsel
jetzt endlich auf die schliche gekommen
klingt sonst hans entwickeln hier gibt's
die spannende science videos abonniert
den kanal und activity glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen ja auf enceladus da wird ja
tatsächlich außerirdisches leben
vermutet haben also diese regelmäßigen
streifen irgendetwas damit zu tun er ist
er einer der spannendsten himmelskörper
überhaupt unter seiner eiskruste
schlummert ein ozean aus flüssigem
wasser zudem gibt es hinweise auf
hydrothermale schlote also auf
unterwasser geysire aus denen heißes
wasser kommen gesteins kern in den ozean
unter dem eis aufsteigt und das wäre
wirklich spektakulär denn dann wäre der
saturnmond der erste himmelskörper außer
der erde mit solchen hydrothermalen
schloten und auch in der nähe dieser
schlote wird eventuell eben
außerirdisches leben vermutet die
lebensbedingungen könnten dort perfekt
sein fest steht jedenfalls enceladus
gilt als möglicher kandidat für
außerirdisches leben doch mindestens
genauso spannend und rätsel haben sind
die tigerstreifen auf der oberfläche von
enceladus absolut regelmäßig dieses
risse sind etwa 130 kilometer lang und
verlaufen fast so gerade und parallel
als seien sie mit einem lineal gezogene
abstand beträgt rund 35 kilometer sie
sehen tatsächlich so aus als hätte ein
tiger seine riesige pranke ins eis
gehauen auf jeden fall ist dieses muster
wirklich einmalig im sonnensystem und so
gibt es forschungsteams riesige rätsel
auf wie kann es sein dass nur dieser
mond über so ein muster verfügt kein
modell konnte die kilometer langes
rissen bislang zufriedenstellend
erklären dazu der us wissenschaftler
dass hemingway diese zuerst von der
cassini mission gesichteten streifen
sind anders als alles bisher aus dem
sonnensystem bekannte keine anderen als
planeten oder monde haben so etwas
um den mysteriösen tigerstreifen auf die
schliche zu kommen nahm das os
forschungsteam verschiedene
physikalische modelle und kombinierte
diese in einer einzigen simulation
das ergebnis ist eindeutig demnach fing
alles mit einem einziges an und zwar
ausgelöst durch die gezeitenkräfte die
auf dem saturnmond wirken der mond wird
ja abwechselnd gedehnt und gestaucht
bedingt durch die exzentrische bahnen
des mondes um den saturn herum das sind
die auswirkungen der gravitation konkret
und kreis der mond den saturn eben auf
einer elliptischen bahn so dass er dem
ringplaneten mal ferner und dann wieder
etwas näher ist wenn der unterirdischen
ozean dann dabei zu eis gefriert dehnt
es sich aus der druck steigt immer
weiter und weiter also nur zur
erinnerung wenn wasser gefriert wird es
als einer der wenigen distanzen dehnt es
sich aus weil das eis ein cristina
kristall strukturen bildet ja und der
eispanzer am pol gab dann aufgrund
dieser ausdehnung nach so entstand der
ersteres dem wir als eine art streifen
wahrnehmen neues ozean wasser ist dann
über diese erste entstanden eiskalte
richtung oberfläche gedrückt worden
der druck wurde dann aber noch größer da
das wasser erneut gevor und den riss
zudem auch noch abdichtete das erklärt
max rudolf einer der beteiligten
forscher folgendermaßen das hat dazu
geführt dass sich der eispanzer gerade
so verbogen hat dass ein weiterer bruch
rund 35 kilometer entfernt entstanden
ist unser modell erklärt die regelmäßige
entfernung der brüche der regelmäßigen
abstand von 35 kilometern ist nach
ansicht der expertinnen experten also
kein zufall
dafür sorgen stabilität temperatur und
dicke der ice kosten diese führen also
dazu dass die spannung in mais in genau
dieser distanz die schwelle zum riss
überschreiten dazu heißt es in der
studie
diese kaskade der rissbildung setzt sich
in symmetrischen paaren nach außen hin
fort das modell des forschungsteams legt
nahe dass diese muster bildung erst dort
endet wo die eiskruste mit zunehmender
entfernung vom südpol zu dick für
durchgehender das wird weil die ersten
risse an der südküste entstanden fiel
der druck der eiskruste ab und
am gegenüberliegenden pohl entstand kein
weiterer bruch die fachleute betonen
dass diese tigerstreifen tatsächlich nur
auf enceladus möglich sind denn nur hier
könne diese kettenreaktion ablaufen
bedingt durch die kleine größe des 500
kilometer großen saturnmondes bei
planeten die größer sind würde das durch
die gravitation verhindert werden und
zwar durch eine stärkere komprimierung
des eises das damit stabiler wäre und
nicht in einem solchen ausmaß
aufgerissen werden kann dazu heißt es in
der aktuellen studie unsere modellierung
der physikalischen vorgänge in der
eiskruste fall in zella los demonstriert
eine potenziell einzigartige abfolgen
ereignisse und prozesse die diese
auffallenden streifen erschuf
außerirdisches leben auf enceladus
anklicken anschauen und astro comics tv
abonnieren hammer kanal und perfekt für
alle die sich für astronomie
interessieren also bis dann bleib dran
und gucken und abonnieren
auf jeden fall